yeah I think human beings right now
should do even temporary marriage
contracts or roll in relationship
contracts and I and I mean this I mean
if you find someone that you actually
want to be with yeah you can laugh it's
true though
you can laugh but the way the divorce
rate is going right now it's like yes I
agree but I'm saying if you have like a
relationship contract that lasts it you
decide with your partner well let's try
this for a year if we're happier after a
year we'll continue the the contract and
within that contract you can stipulate
to your partner and your partner can
stipulate to you exactly what they want
from the relationship and exactly what
they expect from the relationship